what are fractions there's a word in our
language which we use a bit more
frequently than the fraction even though
these are Fabian if you have a bird and
it gets broken into pieces and put the
cost you say you've got up a fracture a
fracture right when something is
fractured it means it's broken into
pieces right or divided into pieces if
you like and so that's what fractions
are about it's like taking the whole
numbers we've dealt with whole numbers
before one two three four five but
thinking about well what if you break
them into pieces that are smaller than
just the holes okay if you have rather
than saying you know okay I've got to
wipe or markets they're whole numbers if
you had part of a whiteboard marker what
would that how would how do we do the
maths with that okay
so as we know it just to review it there
are three kinds of fractions these plays
a fraction that we work we write three
kinds of fractions anyone want to prep
ahead what's the first sort of warm or
kind of fracture to no proper fact it's
very good proper fractions so most of
what you think of when you think of
fractions we'll get to the other two in
a second and our last both of you most
of what we think up our proper fractions
I'd say for example uh-huh is a proper
fraction right or 4/5 or ninety-nine out
of a hundred what makes a proper
fraction proper what is it about yes
okay good
so we got the top of the bottom number
there's something about what are they
called um any point what what's the
bottom one denominator very good and
that makes the top would someone else
what's it called be very not very good
the numerator so if the numerator is
smaller than the denominator right that
means that uh you're going to have a
proper fraction okay the denominator is
how many times do you want to fracture
it how many times you want to break it
up Knight and 100 would be I break it
into a hundred tiny pieces that's the
denominator and then the numerator is
will how many of those pieces do you
okay so four-fifths you'd break it into
five pieces that's it denominator and
then you take four of them that's
numerator if the new rate is smaller and
then denominator you get a proper
fraction but if it's not what happens
yeah Danielle very good improper
fractions improper fractions so this is
just kind of in Reverse right it's if
you have the numerator bigger the other
way around right so for example you
could have three over two
or you could have seven or if you do a
hundred so keep all of the numerators
are bigger than all of the denominators
they're all improper what what are these
popper and these improper yeah you kind
of like there's been a swap thing
happening what were you gonna say Matt
huh good this is bigger than this it's
improper I guess you think about it in
terms of like when you fracture
something it's like you start with the
hole you start with one and then you
break it into pieces so what you get is
less than one right
but all of these guys are more than one
right they're all bigger than one 2 over
2 would be wonder this is three of them
4 over 4 would be 1 and this is 7 of
them and so on okay so since all these
are actually more than one we have
another way to write improper factors
into the last cut yeah yeah mixed mixed
numerals is usually what we call them
but you get the idea they're mixed
because we put together a fraction with
a whole number okay so in fact I'm gonna
write these 3 here so 3 over 2 would be
1 1/2 7 over 4 would be 1 and 3/4 that's
the way I read it as well not 1/2 it's
one and a half not one 3/4 it's 1 and
3/4 and then this guy here would be 1
$1.99 I guess okay and it doesn't have
to be a one out this line that could be
a two or a three or a four
whatever whole numbers we like to
include okay so those are the kinds of
fractions now what to get our head back
in the space in terms of adding and
subtracting these guys adding and
subtracting and there is one key idea
there's one key idea that kind of
catches all the different adding and
subtracting fractions that we're going
to get which is you can put this right
at the top yeah you want to say good
make the denominator or the denominators
identical and if you do that then you
can put together any fractions you like
whether they're proper or improper or
air if they're mixed numerals